teacher that is that a bird it's a plane
no it's a dink oh my god somebody more
it ding ding ding
I was not ready for it everybody welcome
back to the jungle podcast
another fire intro in the books this
week's episode is brought to you by
texture experience the wonderful mists
of having magazines but have it on your
phone leave a normal person now okay do
it realistically with texture with
texture app guys it lets you tap into
the world's most popular magazines
anytime anywhere using your smartphone
or tablet is amazing I'm telling you
you're going to get hooked on it go to
texture calm slash Gemma Julianne right
now to get your free trial and a breeze
through a whole bunch of magazines right
your fingertips also brought to you by
me undies you know it's a tough sponsor
to sell because you can't feel it dirt
like through the camera right now if you
could feel this how do we show wearing
that pair of me undies right now and I'm
wearing another pair look Wow I don't
know how it's called micro moto fabric
fabric Wow and it's super soft twice as
soft as cotton and it's like silk in
your hands alright where every freaking
day
Oh me and these is amazing get yourself
a pair of Mandy's right now you get 20%
off your first purchase by going to meet
undies calm / Jimmy Julian dope designs
as well so thank you to our special
sponsors so today we are doing a part 2
of an older podcast throwback no throw
it this was at the request of you guys
by the way you guys wanted this so this
is your doing you want it you got it you
want it you got it
obviously you yeah we are playing the
newlywed game part 2 we already played
this what a year ago so long no it was
more than a year ago
like two years ago yeah it was like one
of the first podcast that we did it was
right after we moved
to our this place we are still in the
dining room and we had the one person
focused camera were only one of us was
in focus Alberto and actually at the
beginning of that podcast I was talking
about how what we need to get a new
camera for the podcast so yeah basically
the way the newlywed game works for
those who don't know is I prepared 30
questions and we both hey you don't know
that and my bothering you is mine Isis
these 30 questions we always have to
answer them and they're about each other
so basically I'm going to answer what I
think her answers are and then what my
answers are to see if she got them right
is that a good way of explaining it yeah
absolutely but yet it's a test of your
your marriage so you married me so I
didn't actually you did we're not
married and you did happy belated
thirtieth birthday by the way this is
like yeah this is like a week and a half
after your birthday yeah but in real
time right now it's before my birthday
because we're recording it ahead of time
so that I don't have to do it on my
actual birthday yeah cuz I want to do
nothing for my birthday cuz we're going
to Boston next week so this is going to
be a my friends getting married to me
out of town um you guys are you guys
will have already saw the Julian doesn't
know anything about music podcast so
hopefully you enjoyed that but working
at you want to just jump into this hmm
alright just jump into it we did pretty
good in the first one right like we've I
think we did pretty good yeah I feel
pretty confident about these I think if
we hold them up right here the camera is
solid enough that you might be able to
make it out so let's just hold up in
case but we'll also read them out yeah
read them out first because they have
two answers on them yeah yeah alright so
um your significant other or your honors
most irritating bedroom habit who's
going first though like whose answers
are we deciding first yours mine yeah
usually left side as for the rest so
I'll read my answer and then okay no why
don't you read what you wrote first okay
for me so this is what was my most
irritating bedroom oh you're getting
better
hold it up while I said no because it
has to answer fine let you let the dogs
hump each other that's my most
irritating habit like facilitated bed
this is bedroom habit right that's in
the bedroom okay I said that I don't go
to bed I was given that was my second
one he's not sleeping
he gets so mad at me you know just like
roll over it be like are you asleep yet
no that's cuz you like go home I love
sleeping not ready to go to sleep right
now I actually was gonna right thing
just sleep this differently yeah true
that I let the dogs hump each other or
what they want to who am I to say it
like you can't know you like facilitate
it weirdly sometimes you're like alright
marbles sit here peachie lay that way
okay no I could sleep to humper yeah you
can't you can't do that you got to love
each other
all right what's my answer I don't I
don't see how that's yours so you're
saying what's my irritating bed [ __ ] I
said that you're so anti top sheet in
the [ __ ] kick it off and don't put it
on the bed some good old [ __ ] up I
hate it we both hate it like where is
the flat sheet so doesn't matter it's
pointless well you got that wrong what
is it turn off lights without you asking
I wrote that for something else all
right so we're getting there we're
warming up yeah so we're like we'll be
in bed and like I haven't taken out my
contacts yet I'm like sitting there yeah
but sometimes in like my clothes like I
just sort of sat in bed cuz we've gone
upstairs and Julian will like turn all
the lights off I'm like hello I what are
you doing I don't turn them off I start
a sunset okay so it's a gradual turn off
for those of you out there that have
glasses and contacts you realize how
annoying it is when someone turns off
the lights and you haven't even flick
put your glasses on like I'm gonna I'm
not be able to find anything I don't
realize that okay yeah we believe that
we both have we're gonna warm up we're
gonna get there all right that was
really odd that connected all right the
thing that your art likes most about you
so the thing that you think I like most
about you the bot is what I wrote the
bot bot I just I was super generic for
this one what do you get I wrote sense
of humor / sweet
and I wrote
for both well that's funny because I
wrote don't box that's funny
alright my favorite thing about you is
da bomb wow what a great yet shallow
answer well I mean it is the greatest
thing about us both it was true just a
couple of great BOTS over here oh man
thanks buddy
well done da ba I'm sorry is that too
much they're gone yeah I hate that one I
don't like any of this no I like it
it's stay or your most repeated phrase
um this one was hard for me this is how
you you reveal what you thought mine was
I thought yours was it's lit I mean
that's fair enough it's kind of
everyone's I said dad that's your phrase
yeah did I say the most for you I wrote
look that's embarrassing
Julian's most said phrases are I'm
Ottery want to go to the nest and I am
snacky
wait so you just basically boiled my
phrases down to me being tired all the
time and hungry I'm not tired and hungry
else is what it's like living with Julie
oh [ __ ] what is the BB Oh true I say
that all the [ __ ] time be you a BB
would enjoy missed so just can you say
something every day that makes it a
repeated phrase I say you want to go to
the nest meeting you want to go to the
bed and that makes it yeah I feel like
I'm saying that every day you know
categorizes that one of the things that
you say the most all right well I think
your most repeated phrase is the you say
that every day if you wrote that you
probably be right you so I'm snacky
I don't say that I'm snacky snack all
right favorite Pixar movie this was hard
because I did I forget which ones are
Pixar alright I picked for you wall-e I
wrote Finding Nemo for me I was right
for me wall-e
why
we go to Walmart we all Walmart we go to
Walmart she got her basket basket basket
boop boop of a basket basket that was my
noise all right all right biggest pickle
with the cops you got arrested because
he hadn't paid some sort of ticket it up
in Rochester or something yeah that's
actually right got it
that's right that's mine I didn't pay it
because they were sending it to my old
dorm in your head because you're a
criminal I am a criminal I got arrested
in New Hampshire and it was crazy all
right what's mine with marbles I really
want to find that mugshot someday take
two because I was smiling in the first
one and he was like talk to that lady
stop it I look like an absolute [ __ ]
anyways you got a gun pointed at you got
gun pointed presumed theft
I knew that though that's a point of
this game yeah Lamia but you know it
okay I knew that though these sound
effects are just rather I love it
favorite UFC fighter I love it your
favorite UFC fire I wrote is Carlos
Condit ten years is mashita slash GSP
wrong mine is clay [ __ ] guida
Clay Guida Clay Guida anybody anybody
everybody I do this game seriously
because if Clay Guida gets his block
knocked off you don't really care you
care with machine losses you almost cry
yeah that's true and GSP mostly GSP I
can't breathe when he fights
I can't one time I almost breathe the
same air in I did breathe the same air
as you didn't because you weren't
breathing I held my breath because I
couldn't move I was like say hot and
she's like are you [ __ ] insane
I just stood there and didn't breathe
for like a minute I couldn't I was too
nervous oh I can't believe Oh clay clay
guida this game that's a wrong answer
for Julian what are you all clay guida
not even keeping score on clay guida
alright I [ __ ]
get it most I wanna be bothered
OCD at it hmm would you write for me
picking yeah I also wrote picking
picking them so like picking on yeah I'd
like to get Julian's blackheads out
yourself too
oh yeah I like it you like look at me
I'll walk into the room and I'll be like
what happened you be like I hurt myself
I pick - all right I just like it okay
and I also pick it like my my thumb skin
and stuff I just like it I'm sorry it's
just a thing that exists what's my most
irritating OCD have it that you tornado
and blackout in the kitchen nope biting
nails you do not bite drinking tornado
Ling is not OCD this is if someone sees
you while you're cooking you think
you're possessed when I'm when I'm
nervous and I'm obsessive compulsive I
mean it's I know people don't like when
you use that phrase because you don't
have OCD but we're gonna use it on
nervous in a respectful way I bite the
[ __ ] out of my nails like if I'm
watching a movie or a car chase like huh
or I just never noticed because it's
really not that severe I was watching
cops from stepbrothers get up who even
are you God so we just become not best
friends yep TV show that you miss the
most for you I wrote the office correct
what did you write for me though
Zack stone slash utopia oh those are
both so good today I'm both wrong this
is utopia all right so since I went over
to on one question what is the correct
answer
she's crying about utopia because it was
cancelled after not even one high season
[Music]
utopia
let's make a new start
[Music]
is Wednesday my nudes or your beverage
headphones on right sighing you're
amplified voice um for all five of you
that watched utopia if you could just
chime in in the comments
yeah right made me feel better Brett did
Rob did four of you I don't think vibes
kind of we knew a couple people but I
feel like it was just us five you me
Brett and Rome yeah that's why I went
out there after like seven episodes
eight episode wait that's four people
that means Colin though to what was the
show that I wrote yeah mm-hmm highlights
every time I turn off Friday lights
you're like I don't want to watch this
[ __ ] because I said that about their
most miss zhuo I don't care if you've
seen it or not because I don't like
watching things that I've already
watched like what is your favorite show
I feel differently than you do about
favorite things there's only like a
couple of handful of things I like to
watch over and over and I've seen it
like Family Guy I'll watch over an
upside feldsher uh movies like my best
friend's wedding or the Little Mermaid
sure let's watch that again but a lot of
things I'm like I've already seen that I
don't want to sit here during like my
you know hour at night when I'm eating
and want to kick back and relax I don't
want to watch something I've already
watched it doesn't mean feel relaxed it
irritates me I've already seen this why
am I wasting my time watching it again
free watching television that I like is
one of my life's greatest pleasures it's
not for me I rewatched on like series I
like I go into the living room
kick back to relax Julian's watching
season 2 episode 4 of Breaking Bad
they're like no this is not for me I
I've gone on to you for this I don't
know what happened after this I have to
be too emotionally invested in this to
watch the supposed tension it's really
every day you know what so so you're
saying no matter how great a show is
you're literally only going to ever
watch it once no no I said there's a
handful of things that I feel okay
having on and watching if I've seen it
before most of the time
they're like funny and mindless and they
have no like long-term plot that I don't
need to invest to I feel like when you
watch it a second time and you really
like it like for me I'm watching
Breaking Bad right now for me watching
that a second time I just get to sit
there and enjoy the beauty of the show
that made me like it the first the first
time watching like I get to sit there
and just appreciate it knowing what's
gonna happen you do that also expecting
it's like turning on a random episode of
Game of Thrones be like oh I'm just
gonna [ __ ] kick it right now like
there's too much happening some very
different no it's not it's not mindless
or relaxing to me I don't want to pay
attention you know that's Abril
I loved Friday Night Lights it has a
long-term ongoing plot that sometimes
I'm just like this isn't relaxing right
now because I don't know what's
happening let's just agree to disagree
with you fine fine Friday Night Lights
is the show that I miss the most
I can't even count on this one and I
can't count two areas down how many
times I'm trying to turn it on in the
day and she's been like what the hell is
this oh yeah it's the show I miss the
most but what the hell are you doing I
don't want to watch it over and over I
don't know if they were [ __ ] enough I
miss his acts own utopia so I've kind of
wrote those for me but I know you
missing I'm also like a little bit of a
completionist so if you're watching some
random episode of Breaking Bad
I either then need to watch the entire
series or none at all I don't get that I
don't want to watch one exercise I like
randomly what's wrong with an episode
long ongoing plot it ruins that it's
weird okay well here's here's I will
give you this okay
for a show like Breaking Bad I couldn't
really watch turn on TV and watch a
random episode I'm rewatching it's dual
life I'm rewatching the series yeah I'm
watching an episode maybe a day or every
two days right so I'm caught up but I
understand what I'm trying to say so I
understand what you're saying yeah when
it comes to intense shows because for
like Friday Night Lights for the office
for Parks and Rec I can't just put on a
random episode no I'm saying you
probably could I can't because those
aren't shows that I choose to watch over
and over again but but by you watching
an episode here and there of Breaking
Bad and re watching the season I am now
bits and pieces of Breaking Bad I didn't
ask for well to be fair I really only
watch it when you're on I only watch a
little bit when you on the couch because
I didn't know you were awake but you
know I mainly watch it in the office by
myself [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
Julian turn on anything other than this
reason this weekend when you were sick
in the world kappa Yorick yeah you know
it's gonna make me feel great is
watching season 2 episode 4 of Breaking
Bad such a good show
Oh garbage I'm kidding I'm kidding it's
not garbage alright let's move on
favorite store in the mall I think your
favorites are Sephora I wrote Sephora
odds support that's cute because it's
for aughts no because I hold your hand
and I take you in there and you love it
I sometimes ask good questions into
where I've got a lot of knowledge I'm
like I hear like trolls those poor
people and I don't all right they're not
busy I'm asking them questions sometimes
I need to learn about the makeup so I'm
not just that's so embarrassing
alright what's my favorite soda mall
I wrote 9:02 one fo JK it's a place
where you can get fun fun place in the
mall food I'm JK adidas if there is one
put the malt like the mall I was talking
about like the mall we go there I'm
sorry does that answer not good enough
for you oh you're right that's actually
good I wrote Apple Store can I go in
every sale trim yeah I got it wrong too
damn we're not doing so hot or not I'm
alright we're not doing so hot outside
Nick yeah yeah yeah it yeah up okay
favorite climate favorite climate yeah I
mean it was a weird question okay what's
my favorite I said yours is overcast
clouds oh yeah cloudy I wrote that's
like where it came from
one of the most overcast places in the
world yeah so mom I thought you
time-lapse England's clouds growing up
oh I wrote sunny for you yeah I wrote
the one I moved to to dick the one I
live in it took me a lot of effort and
time and thought and effort to get here
so it's the one I live in I like it good
for you
you know many hours of driving it is
it's a lot I like got all the way here
I'm excited and I like it oh I like
clouds we had a really cloudy day today
don't buzzer me we both got it right no
no wow good one favorite alcohol mm-hmm
I wrote yours is whiskey oh yeah uses
wine no my name is not lyin
what it is yes you just look so defeated
sounds fun
well I do like wine i wrote whatever is
in my cup for vodka he did favorite
drink last time to whatever's in my cup
really is is the real answer I'm not
picky I'll drink whatever's in makeup
but I'm picky I like good whisky you are
picky and you do like good whisky what's
your least favorite alcohol gin gin that
Rome [ __ ] made me drink it in London
she was like it's good it's loaded and I
was like okay sounds like that's gin but
why did you give me that it's one was
intelligent it was gin Trojan is
literally red gin yeah no it would yes
Logan is a sweet Regin she gave me pure
straight [ __ ] gin [ __ ] Jen chicken Shin
is what the [ __ ] wrong now you just got
me mad about Rome this is your fault
round we hover on the podcast again yeah
I want to [ __ ] with her all right I know
I know I got that right
wine is your favorite I mean I do like
wine is what kind of wine white wine
Pinot Grigio mmm I like me some Pinot
Grigio new this year fresh enough of
this old wine here some fresh wine this
year I like this question by the way
something that you always carry
yeah I know the answer to yours what's
my flashlight and yours is a Mophie Wow
why don't you both be everywhere I said
phone or lipgloss the food isn't given
though Mophie movie every time you leave
a heart and of a muffin because
something on you is dead it's true it's
so true I mean your answer is probably
more right you okay don't embarrass you
what about you on blasphemy even if I
don't have a phone I have exactly I just
use my cell on you is yeah I will put
your box well quick yeah so funny right
so oh the last few nights Jenna has
literally not few the last like two
[ __ ] weeks Jenna has literally been
bringing the Mophie up to bed putting it
on her bedside table and running the
Mophie out to her phone while she sleeps
instead of plugging her phone into the
wall by her bed like a normal person
what is that I mean if you want me to
change you can just put the long cord
into the wall and then I'll use that
what what has been stopping you from
that and just pure laziness mmm these mo
fees are going to die twice as fast
because you're literally killing them
every night she's like no your Muffy's
you write about flashlights flashlights
always carry a flashlight always only a
flashlight
you should write favorite non youtube
website uh yours I wrote is reddit
correct
and I wrote yours is the Daily Mail ooh
Daily Mail and blank awesome yeah I was
gonna write blind guy actually what do
you like mommy's oh oh just trying to
take those Julie oh my god stop it
Kimmy oh my god what's your favorite pit
to tickle - can you tip it while I Drive
you're Canadian
I managed hit - tickle well you have a
choice of two unless you're tickling
like a [ __ ] avocado pit or a carpet
carpet he has a lot of pits he does
don't he's like here's like the forward
arm and it is not his real like face pit
and yes is like the soul pit that he
lives in I like to pickle
soeul pet oh my god pickle don't soap it
don't say pickle like that don't say
pickle is over that's your favorite hi
I'm Jenna nice to meet you welcome to
speed-dating okay a question number one
what's your favorite pick to tickle
[Music]
what's your favorite pit to tickle and
what's your favorite pit to be you
tickled what's your favorite tit to
pickle oh I would say mmm the tit and
the type of tip hell yeah all right we
nailed that one what will what will the
fourth pet be our house
oh I've even meet him and what do I
think is the fourth pet what do you
think well I would be yeah there won't
be one
oh come on I wrote if you answer it
answer it now my answer it's valid again
owner cuz that's [ __ ] wrong if I had
to pick obviously eventually I want a
fourth pepp it pick one ah then whip it
got it right
see all you had to do is apply yourself
Jenna Wow Wow
I said hairless cat all right I wrote a
small list that says either a a rescue
greyhound named jenna Marbles
who's from that one shelter and I feel
like if there's ever a rescue dog with
your full name your obligation is
getting wrong named after you is just
you have an obligation as a human being
to adopt that dog if it has your full
name it's just gonna be right and I
really want it be a silken wind hound
named Gary see poodles a standard poodle
named Gary D a whippet named Gary II a
hairless cat who does not have a name
yet yeah def a human baby orgy all the
above all right well I got right cuz you
wrote hairless cat I think we should
name our hairless cat 11 hell yeah
cuz it looks like 11 in the show she's
bald wait what do you mean our hairless
cat if we got a hairless fat after we
got the Whippet but so are you giving me
a hairless cat remember give me with it
for my birthday sure if she passing out
the other dish was like hey on my
birthday this week are you gonna give me
a hairless cat yeah yeah are you gonna
get us a new landlord that's gonna allow
it the only one for my birthday it was a
new pet
well you're not getting it
already known that she that's all I want
sometimes you can't have what you want
baby or puppy no right not you are it's
not my choice is the landlord we can't
have one three vets there's a clause
you could negotiate okay let's negotiate
but can we finish the podcast first city
for my birthday it's getting this one
today and all can we skip to this one
there likes sake sort of just copped in
the mic very psych upset I'm sorry can
we skip take the two off and skip to the
third one down it's this one which so
save these soon yeah okay current
favorite app what's my current favorite
app um I wrote reddit I didn't know this
one was tripping me up I'm look at the P
I was gonna write read it but then I
cross it on wrote post mates
I guessed hearthstone for you yeah
Hearst I wrote horse dot hot brats
hearthstone yeah but in actuality our
favorite app is texture oh my god which
when it comes to magazines guys you know
what you like texture you can get all
the magazines you want in one convenient
place guys Billboard magazine Brides
magazine Canadian business canadian
health and lifestyle Car and Driver any
sort of magazine you desire you can get
on the texture app right on your phone
guys because of pizza we're all binge
eating because of Netflix we're all
binge watching but now with texture you
can start binge read yes let's get this
going let's start binge reading guys
it'll suggest articles not only
magazines but suggested articles from
textures team so that they see what
you're reading and their team will
curate things for for you specifically
which is super awesome because then
you'll discover things you might not
have ever known you would have liked I
personally like Men's Fitness and men's
health I also like men's fitness and how
weird I also like Good Housekeeping
another step on this boat right over
your head
favorite non-pornographic we're not even
married to master Victor but ask you get
it out keep it anyway go to texture comm
slash gender Julie right now get your
free trial going and you will not be
sorry
thank you texture and other semester is
the wonderful meet undies these
beautiful undies right here and he's
been had been had been supporting us
they've been supporting us our OG
sponsor guys you know that there's
something to be said about that they're
a super loyal sponsor and they are
awesome and you know what's awesome is a
lot of the times when you guys tweet at
us that you have new minis I will see me
and he's responding which is super cool
they're they're they're awesome they're
great company people and they make soft
and weird place as soft as cotton it's
called micro modal fabric and the
shipping is always free for all orders
in US or Canada
guys get your mayonnaise and every month
they have a brand new design like their
designs are so sick this is the one I
have on it's going to make you wanna mmm
thank you it's best if I break you next
to being naked in fact sometimes I'll
just wear my undies around the house so
no that is just absolutely true I do
just check her snapchat I'm like oh
we're not complaining until I'm trying
to snatch at new like don't snapchat me
own new Codel our favorite things about
each other as the bots so get some
Mandy's dal bhat ah check out me undies
coms last Jenna Julianne to get your 20%
off your first order and let us know how
you like it me undies is the best
underwear you can buy Thank You stocks
pretty soft very soft Thank You sponsors
pret cannot let your me undies on over
my undies neon V I appreciate it if you
didn't cuz they're mine and I want them
all right we going back to these I'm so
caffeinated right now but I can tell you
like it has this your second coffee yeah
I wanna know is it okay gimme all right
go ahead I have it but give me it like
permission II was just you a squad isn't
it
you don't ASMR swallow a lot of your
one Yoon se already ready favorite cheat
meal all right I wrote yours was is
formerly when these bacon aiders is now
a sushi or that one time though we made
the vegan lasagna
oh damn it what is it fresh pros oh [ __ ]
I didn't even think that pizza ice bros
pizza I'm an idiot yeah but yours is
talked about mmm I wrote RFD you're just
extra Genovese see RFD is one of my
other answers dang it we're getting
close marty is real food daily which is
like a really wonderful vegan restaurant
well they're really far away I think
i'ma take her out there for her birthday
this week I don't want to what I think
don't we go there we started wanna go
out to dinner together all right
favorite shoe or sorry favorite shoe
brand or favorite shoe store either one
yours is adidas correct what's mine chic
whoa you got it yeah she like spelled
Shi e KH and there is there in a lot of
malls it's just like choose yeah they're
not very expensive they're just like my
favorite cuz I have a hard time buying
expensive shoes did not work it to me
they're always really nice in there -
yeah they're yeah maybe that one guy
knew me he's like you have all of these
already is there anything new I can get
you like we showed up every problem and
I still wear like all of them they don't
die well you don't feel like 40 bucks
you expect him to die or like really
hurt your feet or something they don't
die they've lasted me years a lot of
those yeah in the most respectful way
man chic damn in the most respectively
impossible um they have a lot of good
hoochie ho hooker [ __ ] that you like
hell yeah you know my shoe style I do
hooky help hooky how someone had touch
me how happy me all right best friend
question mark Jackie yeah I wrote chase
or peach or me Oh magic correct
or teacher me oh really that fan stop
yeah we made a gross yeah
something that you do specifically to
annoy your OTT okay when you press a lot
of times it's not a kiss anymore it's
like a psycho baby like don't imagine
just like a demon baby from that game
god what's that game daddies your daddy
yeah wait is it was your daddy all right
all right in the back there clever you
know they're my sound effects if you
want yours you can download something
you do to annoy your OTT mm-hmm
something you do to annoy me is you COO
it the dogs pass the amount that's
accepted I wrote sing to the dogs
correct awesome what do I do
that annoys you I just wrote in all
capital letters paper towels ha military
time the words I mean there's just so
many how am I supposed to pick one hmm
gets on his high horse about military
time you change everything in the house
have military time and then you get mad
what I'm like I don't know what five you
guys know you might care because I don't
want to use military time not change
it's the military time I'm changing my
devices to military time not what do you
smell eteri time I hate it no
specifically sometimes would be like
what time is that not be like 2100 and
she'll be like Jillian what the [ __ ]
shut up but I never like say military
time to her unless I want to piss her
off
which is fun all right paper towels
because whenever you like use the paper
towel in the kitchen he'll use it for
one thing crumple it and then leave it
on the counter no everyone knows all
right round the kitchen be like are you
done with this yeah you like snarkily
ask like are you definitely shut up
favorite gift from your aunt I wrote
that yours is the drone that I gave you
drone Joan hmm I just for a ring um I
wrote the dog or cat you're giving me
from everything oh my god and I just get
any real otter ring oh and Audrey oh I
love you but mostly it's so cute that
you're also wearing it right I don't
have to get the room
I was putting on lotion in the other um
the dog or cat that you're getting me
for my birthday's gonna be my favor you
can go back to the troll answer you
already let that was what makes you
think that's a troll answer I'm not
getting you a cat for your birthday all
right I'm gonna expect that it's gonna
be here on Thursday right my birthday no
no this can be a joint gift we sign up
for each other for Christmas I like your
birthday and when we're going out to
dinner someone's bringing over a small
crate with a cat or a dog
I'm waiting respectfully and
disrespectfully no I'm not gonna buy you
cut if we go be an aisle there'll be a
joint gift okay relax so snappy all
right do you want a boy or a girl
Julian wants a girl and would you write
you want a boy yeah Julian wants a girl
and I want a boy yeah I want a boy
because I want them to look like you I
want to go if I want her to look like
you know it's all just not eating what
were you eating the other day you're
sitting there on the couch like any in
style with your legs and your hair was
in the pigtails and you're eating corn
on the cob and you just look like the
cutest little kid knows I want my kid to
look like that I love corn on the cob
cute you know my corn on the cob them I
know why would I eat that so good
disgusting cute kid but so so good I
never got that like when we first
started dating you like we're so anti
corn you use a little bit of corn yeah
the only quantity is like popcorn or
sometimes if corns in a stir-fry or
something I love corn corn is useless
don't say that nonsense corn is
delicious in queenship corn tortillas
and corn chips there's no time I can't
eat regular flour tortillas tortillas
toward toward someone that hates corn
oil a lot of corn
I don't corn I eat corn based products
mmm corn base favorite social media
I wrote the years of snapchat and yours
is Twitter yeah I wrote Twitter or
YouTube
because I do like YouTube I don't I like
Twitter so much is your ons with an on
top which is great I love to it it's
easily mice I would say my second
favorite but you know if I had to like
pick one to keep between snapchat and
Twitter I would keep Twitter
I feel like snapchat is cool but I end
up just skipping through a lot of people
story same time Twitter's are so helpful
for like news Twitter is a very
practical social media you can get a lot
of info from it and have a good time
just getting mine's Facebook get out all
right two things that you do before a
bedtime all right two things that you do
before bedtime is you take off your
makeup and you take out your contacts
yeah that's fair enough
I wrote get marbles is bear play
hearthstone and take out my contacts
basically right yeah anyway right I
wrote that you check reddit and complain
that jenna doesn't want to turn the
lights off yet and crash and nice I'm
right no you're absolutely it's broken
wrong I'll say that you um take off all
your clothes except for your me undies
usually everyone does that everyone
that's another thing like do your bed
everyone close your eyes some things I
do which I expected you to know before
bedtime is I take zma and I turn on the
AC or open the window I true those are
two things that you should know about
you that I do every night
I'd say get water and bring it upstairs
with you like a giant thing down bring
my jug of water every night and um no
we're done with this answer you don't
get to keep guessing no it's over come
over and kick the flat sheet all the way
to the bottom of it stop it stop it
right now
stop it if you know what's good for you
stop it right now um you reach over Eddy
to go like this and you go I love you oh
I do do that yeah when you do that you
sleep - I do yeah hmm you wake up like
every time night all right let me do
side joggers like to little wake up like
a hundred times
the foreleg asleep wake up like look
over at me and I'm just sitting there
[ __ ] silently there's like silent and
who'd be like can you lower the volume
of the TV or like lower the volume on
something that it's like I'm completely
[ __ ] silently sitting there and
you'll make it somehow seem like I'm the
reason that you can't sleep so they just
keep like waking up sometimes I will be
dead asleep and something that you're
watching will have a moment I don't know
like some yeah like on Hulu when they
play the commercial super laughs yeah
like there are spikes and audio that
wake me up and then I'm I'm then I wake
up so I'm just freshly woken up so
anything I hear is loud so I look at the
tee I'm like this is so loud and you're
like you've been sleeping this whole
time and like that's it
that [ __ ] was loud thanks for where so
you'll wake up and not have any idea how
long you've been asleep and like I
haven't like I haven't slept at all I
really you suck you've been asleep for
like two hours Julian anybody sleep I'm
a baby when it comes to sleep I know
that I know that if I mean mmm all right
three things that you'd grab in the
house fire mine go hand in hand I wrote
for you yeah dogs your follow and your
special shoebox I mean that's fair yeah
I just wrote page Kermit and marbles
because I assume those are three
separate things can't even barely carry
all three of them at once
yes you can you put the Iggy's in one
Harmon to hold the beep on top like he's
some sort of torch
he is the torch on the Statue of Liberty
he's the torch and these are the books
ok fair enough that's what we should be
following say what it were mine I wrote
phone flashlight away we'll wait so you
would grab the dogs but I wouldn't pull
because Michael handed and I said if I'm
grabbing all three dogs then you
wouldn't have to grab three dogs again
that's what I'm saying that's why I
didn't write dogs so given that you
already grabbed the dog right what I got
phone flashlight in your camera that's
awesome I wrote phone dogs camera so you
had two out of three well yeah if
someone already has a dog that with a
road flashlight yeah well I figured if
if there's a fire you want your
flashlight and my camera
exactly oh I can't wait till we get to
that question my question my question
instrumental it's like musical
instrument you used to play genna's is
the clarinet yeah but I also used to
play the piano the nose flute and the
recorder so clarinet and clarinet and
what is mine I didn't know yeah did I
really trumpet because I don't know oh
no you didn't say trumpet remember
trumpet sat behind me like infants Oh
Sam's opponents no I was sitting in a
chair yeah everybody sits and chills
well sometimes yeah if the trumpets are
behind you hmm what am i you sat in a
chair it's a reference in chairs okay I
just thought they were standing because
they were annoying
okay clarinet no no checking no
sexcellent no woodwind brass horn oh my
god you know funny is that I didn't even
think of the French horn because nobody
ever [ __ ] thinks about French horn
how dare you I played it that used to be
like my go to Craigslist post whenever I
was looking for roommates because that
one I was like renting out a room in the
in the place where I had the master
lease or whatever the place I lived for
years and years in Boston and I was
looking for a roommate on Craigslist and
this girl came in and took a tour of the
apartment was like um I play the French
horn and I need to practice for like six
hours a day and it's a rather loud brass
instrument and I was like can you please
get the [ __ ] out sing then I would
always post in my Craigslist post like
no French horn players which seems like
a ridiculous thing to write until I met
Julie didn't realize that he used to
play French horn though I mean out of
here I get that you don't want to hear
the loud French horn playing her problem
as a French hornist
if I might say is that she practiced you
don't ever need to do that well I'm just
glad it's a difference
okay you go to classy about it and then
you pretend you're sick when you have
concerts I did it and that's how
everyone should do it honestly truly
know I was good at clearing a hallway
backed out of concert I never went on
stage ever I didn't I know that
[ __ ] [ __ ] weren't you and your mom
let you do that
my mother would have killed me so she's
like go to baseball practice remember ah
Kylie did because I had to and because I
loved it and I'm a French one is full
but no I was like really good and I did
like solo fest and stuff or you go and
perform in front of judges by yourself
and then sight-read in front of that she
had much play by memory and said I loved
it well if you liked it then do it but I
didn't like it
French was the bane of my existence Wow
first I dropped it once a big dent and
it was a rented horn - it wasn't mine I
still have my clarinet I do not have my
French on it was not mine Oh No all
right all right moving on favorite
home-cooked meal for both I wrote
Genovese Dobbs see I was gonna read out
of these two but I wrote pasta for you
and rice for me but fair enough we've
been having so much like I tell the
story really quick or whatever so first
of all pasta Gemma BC is pasta with
pesto and and potatoes and green beans
and like salt and pepper and stuff and a
little bit of cheese but like you
wouldn't think that pasta and potatoes
go together so bizarre but it just makes
this like fake sort of pesto sauce sort
of on top of the pasta it's amazing it's
it's delicious it's I don't want to
right now yeah so we are what like I'm
so sorry
we're watching the finale of bachelor in
paradise and I preface this really quick
when I watch TV shows while eating a
certain food
he gets conditioned I get I'm like it's
a classical condition yeah it's like the
TV show plate like for instance when I
use the Wendy's the leftovers
I would taste like Wednesday Wendy's was
like I needed the intro music would come
on and he would just start salivating
for Wendy
that was literally me so every show i
watch not every show but most shows that
I associate with her food that's kind of
how my brain works anyway go trim so we
are watching the finale of bachelor in
paradise which Julianne we've been
making pasta Gemma BC a lot lately
and to the point where it's on Mondays
and Tuesdays and chances are if we don't
watch on a Monday or Tuesday we're
watching another day of the week and
there's a good chance of reading Jenna
VC on one of those days or nights or
whatever and we're watching the finale
and it's super lake's we were catching
up on like a Friday or Thursday night or
something super late yeah
we're in bed it's like midnight not
dinner time at all mm-hmm and Evan is
like on his knee proposing to Carly and
I know they weren't kneeling yet they
were standing there and every both
crying oh yeah they're both crying and
Evan is like I would die for you and
Julian just looks up in the air and goes
oh I taste Jenna via syriza but like you
wouldn't even know we're like you
weren't trying to be funny you weren't
making a joke you are that like hungry
for pasta Genovese see in that moment
taste was that he said it goes like this
goes I love you so much Carly I would
die for you
I taste Jenna VC right now like you
weren't even paying attention I mean I
was but I knew it was gonna happen and
I'm spoiled by that on Twitter so so
yeah me too a little bit OTP by the way
oh my god it's taking all of them there
kid anyways Genevieve Genevieve you guys
try it yeah it's it's just pasta with
you chopped up like a potato or a potato
in half and you boil it till it's cooked
and then you put the pasta and the
material into a 1
with like a pesto sauce and some green
beans and it's delicious mm-hmm foam
pepper and cheese some beverages city
that you move to I wrote Austin for both
of us
I run awesome for me in Montana for you
yeah I wrote know where Montana
underneath also because it's not a city
oh yeah know where Montana where
Montaigne like the middle of winter it's
a gap between two cities so there's not
actual city that nothing is there any
place like that on earth where there's
like no cut like there's a city here and
it's it either but in between it's like
a spot with no city I'd love to live
there you know there's lots of places
like desert is there any place like a
single even one place like that on earth
I'm just asking about one if favorite
restaurant to dine at what's mine
I wrote anywhere with sushi sugar dish
yeah Dan yours is real food daily mine
is this is a trick question
I don't like dining out but yeah it
would be real food nor enough I don't
like going up to dinner I don't want to
go out to dinner on my birthday
whoa no I want to go out to do it right
this is the question I'm excited about
what camera do you use
all right what camera do I use you use
some Sony garbage a7x or some [ __ ] like
that garden wait say the name again of
it a 7ex clothes
there's closer than I thought you got
yeah it's a 7s mark 2 and don't dare you
use the word far [ __ ] are describing my
camera garbage a 7 garbage garbage
garbage oh my god his burp again here's
a candid ad trash mine is cannon or die
a TDM 60d trasher die see 100 or die
yeah see 100 that's what we shoot the
podcast on what's vloggy
canon g7x g7x a DD 6 CD let's trash the
ever that is believe I ever use it can't
get the hook-up right last question of
the day we will get this right for sure
if you're for real you'll get this right
what is my least favorite food because
you're
is seafood oh I wrote what I wrote your
favorite food biases least favorite I
know my swing correctly in yours
incorrectly give me a second I'm gonna
think what's mine here's a seafood
that's a given alright suits your
fashion girl
but what's my least favorite least
favorite food you mean aside from corn
mm-hmm um corn corn eggplant if it's on
my plate and I'm starving I still won't
eat it doing no come on this that's
cheating I feel like that's a great
answer
um let me think I'll think if it's on
your plate and you're starving you won't
eat it hmm at least favorite will be
here we'll wait we got nothing to do no
give me a hint it gives me gas broccoli
yeah hey no rocket I can't eat it well
we recently discovered that you sort of
what's the name of the I forget there's
a name for like cauliflower and broccoli
there's a name for that category we
figured it out because you don't eat a
lot of broccoli anyways but the name of
like that tree like vegetables yeah
because we're making those Buffalo
cauliflower bites which I so [ __ ]
love and crush yeah but it was like
really upsetting Julianne stomach and we
figured out that it's broccoli and
cauliflower and other vegetables like
that that unsettle your stomach yeah
like really bad yep um flowering head
I'm trying not me though fam I can eat
such a breakfast lunch and dinner is BAE
yeah I can't find what the [ __ ] thing
is flour head well there it is there it
is the newlywed newlywed Oh game part
two
thank you guys for watching and thank
you for suggesting questions on Twitter
I appreciate it go get yourself some me
and these strip naked New York dots be
happy and then go on the texture app and
read all your magazines in imagine if
you're in a bathroom right and you're
you're just like enjoying it over - yeah
and there's no magazines you know yeah
I'm alright here touch it Kiera sponsors
yeah thank you sponsors that was fun
this is fun this is the mote I feel like
this is the most fun I'm gonna have this
week until I take you out to dinner this
is the most one I'm going to have this
week until you surprised me with the cat
or puppy that you you're getting all
right if I tell you there's like a 10%
chance you might get a cat will you come
to dinner no even for 10% nope not this
cat here waiting for me when I get home
there's a 10% chance of that that is a
lot no there's still a 10% chance of it
so you say it is a chance you know what
I really want to do because you're not
going to get me a cat who's ever
neighbor cat that is that hangs out
there always I did jeez now love it I'm
like oh no whose kid is this well it's
like trying to get out of the house
there's a goalie across the street yeah
just take it up it up no cat nap cat nap
look at that cut it you love you ding
Pham thanks for hanging on your game
yeah we'll see you in the next one bye
[Music]
you